at midnight you have to play game why
it's just something we do when someone
new joins the family a game what game
all right so we're gonna start off with
the horrifying children's games because
obviously this is a horrifying version
of hide-and-go-seek so chutes and
ladders how would you make it horrifying
real wait this takes I can't I'm er
station ladder there snakes a lot of -
so we just put snakes and chutes and
others oh I have no idea how do you make
that more scary I just like snakes and I
mean you climb a long time since I've
played this game yeah we're of it you
climb up the ladder and then if you get
on the chute that means that you lose
and you go to the bottom but I think if
maybe the ladders had like knives on it
instead of wrong so this one's a little
bit more for you Samir but what's the
time mr. wolf did you play that as a kid
that's an Australian game it's similar
to our version of red light green light
but how could you make what's the time
mr. wolf real wolves all right I don't
think you can bring snakes to monopoly
to make it more horrifying what would
you do for monopoly just care kids yes
to make it terrible billionaires
oh that's truly evil always a big bully
yeah so similar to things anyway does
that uh what about tag how would you
make tag horrified snakes
thank you tag them with a snake hey
that's actually brilliant all right
operation hmm get children to do the
operation you're really good at this
game leave the stuff in the body like
add nails put nails inside like dude
like bad operation yeah terrible
operation that's good all right la bow
all right a couple more uh
duck-duck-goose
dad dad you have to shoot the dog that's
the more you hit him on the top of the
head so maybe you like yeah with water
guns oh well babam
that's even meaner but duck duck you're
supposed to do it softly but like you
could like snake strangle him with his
name all right if y'all can work in
snake the hot potato
snake potato
do they know okay I know some places do
so I mean I'm just just curious I've
seen this but alright that's it I didn't
think Australia with some crazy land you
said you wanted to eat it so this sort
of premise starts at a wedding so what's
your worst wedding Horror Story I mean
how many weddings have you been to a few
have you do you have a good one good
Horror Story I mean usually there's
someone that gets drunk divorced people
do get drunk off it was a really sad um
bridesmaid who made a speech about her
breakup and like the room just cleared
it was fair it was really sad and
awkward was she drinking yeah well I'm
from the south
I can tell you about a lot of rednecks
to get drunk at weddings I'm from I'm
from Alabama good excuse to like lick
I wrap up the speech they're always like
oh my god me and Diane we're best
friends
we just call each other cookie sisters
because oh whatever
and then at the end they're like anyway
I love you so much I love Ben
Ben's great I love you guys so much I
love you guys oh my god just give me the
dessert and I just want to add the
comedy of asking that to the woman that
started four weddings and a funeral is
definitely not did you guys get to play
hide and seek on set like I figured like
you have to write like to just do some
kind of game thank you guys for playing
games like word games yeah my cuz this
crazy game that makes you want to kill
yourself dark is that is a really nerdy
game it's like it's so nerdy it's very
yeah you get you come up with the word
it's five letters no repeating letters
and then the person has to guess how
many that's so bad this is death but
that's what we play a word game oh did
you like text it to each other or like
at the end I was like I need again you
should get really upset yeah I can it be
like a big scene and you'd be like hang
on us some people would get it in like
six guesses and I had five pages nope
but I didn't get better did we play
something else oh yeah play with me so
me and my sister when we were really
little we made up this game and we for
lack of a better word we were little so
we called it the elephant
and I should mock basically your hands
become else oh yeah so I have to walk a
walk and then you have to try and get
the other person so you know and then I
could fly and then I'm big in Australia
with just me Morgan and now me and now
you so there's a lot of like prosthetics
and blood and like practical effects in
the film so who had the most fun with
the prosthetics or like the makeup and
all of that kind of stuff yeah look Hank
and did you guys get to play around with
anything I mean you guys get kind of the
hand one yeah but you are covered
employed a lot but that was the extent
of it that's my next question what's the
does the blood taste like something
delightful is it gum caramel syrup yeah
so who got doused in the most I guess
you yeah what was that day like
delicious caramel syrup for them for the
guts and in its they used banana and
jelly so it's like dessert the only
downside is it gets very sticky the
eyelids can't open after a while and you
go hmm so this is my my next question
you cuz this is not the type of film
date I've seen you and normally like I
said like so was this like all right I
want to go Chandra or what exactly made
you be like let's go get bloody let's go
good yes sir it was a great script it's
a really well-written fun and it's a
brilliant idea I thought it was it's
extremely clever and the it has also a
lot of humor in it so it's not your
typical just horror movie like you're so
scared even though there are a lot of
amendments where you are scared and
there's
and amazing gore it's really bright and
funny and has a comic timing grin
opportunity for great comic timing and
fun to get to work with wonderful
beautiful young people the first thing I
did was I went from we got in fight we
had to fight I've never been in a fight
so I was winging it just trying to
figure out how to do it you look great
but I hit you in the head
oh you were fabulous you gave me a black
eye and then I remembered it was like Oh
wasn't a black guy but it was a good
student I give you a black eye now you
take a black eye but it was a bruise I
had an egg you know how sandy and then
she gave me an itch she gave me an egg
but what was really funny thinking back
on it think back on it is they weren't
really helping us at first right so we
were only in this room with a pad and
all that trying to figure out how we're
gonna do this fight scene and we was we
were just but if I don't like I'm gonna
go at it 100% you know know how back
right yeah even in the even that's like
figuring out with no one right we're
professionals here just stop the whole
thing and they were like no no stop they
made everybody leave the room it was
very dramatic
you know I'm hurting this is the
rehearsal for the same it was the first
I got boxing they had it was an accident
but the drama behind it oh yeah they
well they thought maybe it's like Andie
McDowell's gonna know I just knew if we
put ice on it right away
if you ever had one I have had one of
those but I'm normally the person that
walks around with a baseball bat on my
forehead for a week and a half cuz I
didn't think of the ice there yeah if
you ice it'll go down um so that kind of
brings me the next question um did you
guys have to do like specific training
to get ready for it like nothing they
just kind of threw you guys in there
yeah
that sounds about ready for this movie
actually about that makes a lot of to
look sloppy and
see and the stump team are really great
in keeping it look like we didn't we
want fighters but making it very very
safe awesome alright I have just a
couple more questions what was your
favorite hiding place as a kid like in
your house or home I love to hide
outside but that's what we we used to
play sardines or kick-the-can which was
one of my did you ever play kick-the-can
the kid so much fun well you know you
play yes yeah yeah it's a it's a version
kind of like I guess like kind of like
hide-and-seek but not really it's more
like sardines as hide-and-seek it almost
exactly right
well one person yeah one person hi and
then you find him you get in and kick
the can is he's one person yet and you
might do that remember that thing you do
with your hands used to be this thing
will you do with your hands anyway so
the person that's it has to count you go
hide and then you run in and kick the
key yes and you're safe yes so you have
to get to the can it's like reverse hi
good it's basically kind of like get
back here that comes yeah before
somebody catches you
[Music]
you